[Music]
when you were young and sitting too
close to the harsh blow of that boxset
television your console was attached to
dreams came all too easy hundred these
two words very easy over sublime but for
me it has much more me
[Music]
it's alive it bang is slinging the gun
is loaded
for 100 days
you know what I sir
Dong's wrong
hundred bears stay on your seat
champions hundred thieves for me is my
life every decision I make in every
piece of content I produce really every
breath I take is to take hundred thieves
to a greater place
[Music]
nothing is gonna be handed to you you're
gonna have to work hard for everything
that you want in life and so for me 100
thieves you got to put a hundred percent
of yourself and a hundred set of
everything that you do and go and take
what's not given
when Matthew nadeshot Hague finished his
professional career he was lost at the
time I just didn't know what I wanted to
do and I didn't have anything that
define myself I didn't have anything to
find nature anymore I didn't have
anything that's applying Matthew Bakke I
mean I didn't I didn't know what I was
doing I was just trying to make sure
people would still interested in who I
was post competition one of Call of
Duty's most beloved stars and gaming's
largest personalities
nadeshot moved from Chicago to LA in the
hopes of building something bigger
something that existed after Gigi was
called and the lights went out
under these two words very easy to
oversimplify but for me it has much more
meaning than that when you look at life
it's not easy it's not a simple thing
it's not something that you can just
breeze through it's a series of ups and
downs and spirit a series of obstacles
and challenges that you need to overcome
yourself you need to go into every
situation you need to wake up every
single day knowing that you're gonna
have to go and take what's not given to
you I think for me that's what the
definition of a thief is so there it was
a new organization dedicated to being
more than just joysticks and keycaps a
lifestyle not just a game nature started
the brand as a way for fans of the
eSports and gaming world to latch on to
a fashionable name they felt connected
to fashion had already crept into his
own YouTube content so starting with
apparel and call of duty during the
black ops 3 era felt like a natural fit
[Music]
it looks fresh it makes me mad that
we're not selling it or hit when I
talked about me returning to competitive
call duty it was it was more or less if
I if I want to if I want to compete
again and I decide to compete again it's
gonna involve me you know basically
starting my own team okay and like I
have a dope name for the team that I
think that I've really fallen in love
with I just have a lot of ideas and
plans and a lot of things for the future
and that's really where I'm at right now
so there he was with the name a logo and
a bunch of promises but where do you go
next well in short you chased the money
late in 2017 and early in 2018 the
hot-button topic across the eSports
world was franchising massive investors
from the world of traditional sports and
entertainment were looking to invest
millions into eSports awards and one of
those awards was a hundred thieves who
received a multi-million dollar
investment from cleveland cavaliers
owner dan gilbert that would allow them
to purchase a coveted slot in the newly
franchised na LCS
I don't want to beat around the bush any
more than I have to so I'm just gonna
say it and then we're gonna talk
specifics so my company 100 thieves has
received a multi-million dollar
investment from Dan Gilbert the owner of
the Cleveland Cavaliers to help me build
my business overnight a hundred thieves
went from a name and a logo to a
multi-million dollar eSports
organization with its footing in the
world's biggest game now it was time to
put a team together 100 thieves took an
aggressive approach from the get-go they
weren't looking to start small they
wanted to win right away and so they
went out and signed the hottest free
agent on the market and surrounded him
with talented veterans we are so
incredibly proud and excited to welcome
Afro MU as the support player for the
hunt these rocks are moving into the
2018 LCS we got a fro move on paper the
team had the star power to compete with
na zest and early on that's exactly what
they did
one more hit hyper is gonna have to
connect once again crimson rush just
about to come up impact alive someday
just under turn off the visit comes out
you did not back up that ya pumped in
the ball those hundred these gonna turn
around and maybe try and save them
Sunday read fight TV it's gonna save me
oh she goes back in and that party finds
that smile under her knee what a
turnaround from the feed it's not like
TSM are bleeding out but now it might be
quarks are gonna be caught out there how
chrome ooh
initiating things in
as Mike I'm gonna have that path did ba
TSM hopping away the blob let's crawl
back together but they crawled to the
grave and heading into the spring 2018
playoffs a hundred thieves look primed
to win it all that is until the finals
rolled around five to six boats are
coming in from the side of the thieves
have found themselves in a very
precarious spot they retreat this could
very well be where the game ends someday
down the target on the front line a
double kill for SS Ryu is the last man
standing we shall not stand for long
they've all been to the final stage
being as victorious together
quit or your North American LCS spring
split champions I'm so proud of you guys
regardless you have five players who
never played it together with each other
a lot of you guys who a lot of people
didn't think so had it he just [ __ ]
crushing this finish first four hundred
eases and first it's our first year ever
and you guys did so much more than we
could have ever expected and I want to
thank you from the bottom of my heart
seriously thank you thank you thank you
it was a bitter ending to an impressive
run in their first ever LCS split but
undeterred they kept the ball rolling
securing a second consecutive playoff
berth in the summer but things did not
go as planned if Camille comes in I can
stop the backline brackets inside the
backline when Camille I'll tease you sir
he's looking for a plank they know that
he's there there's the angle find
someone at the end who gets the first
lock up but now I remember the head
butts gonna move on the back end or the
rest of his team all they're trying to
disengage go home solo he's gonna have
to be resurrected by the car no shift it
off this down
way home to the
next admitted killer in the camp then
there's the condor sunday finally loses
that guardian angel its talk or
something
watch his head they got to kill a
chicken
damn
wishing down and finally the fans can be
proud
despite getting knocked out of the
summer split playoffs their back-to-back
playoff appearances landed them a spot
at Worlds representing North America an
incredible feat for a first-year team
but like in the summer playoffs it
wasn't meant to be for v3 the Chasen
bow-legged of fighting a snapper but i
froze over the wall still the kills
coming through fathom serious and IG
knocked on everyone except that zombie
and except aphromoo IG gotta be 5 and 0
we know the base is gonna fall bow after
Safra maybe a close fight on this one
but it's certain the Nexus dropping 1 in
400 thieves the best they can do is
battle to hold on the 3rd place
IG undefeated coming to the last game of
the group stage they were hit the face
with just how good world-class teams are
and at the same time they were catching
heat from fans for their fractured
lineup meteos was traded out of the blue
and Cody Sun was benched without notice
for the entirety of worlds there was an
elephant in the room in LCS community
and that was a recent trade that we made
and I just want to talk to you guys
about this trade just because we
definitely have done a poor job with our
messaging and there's one thing that we
have done a ton of self-reflection about
and we've learned a lot about I want you
guys to know that we're going to get
better it it really hurts me personally
that the organization itself is taking a
lot of heat for it specifically just
because the story that is shown is a lot
different than what people see I want to
admit that was my lack of understanding
of this world that I have not been a
part of throughout my entire career and
that is where I'm very disappointed in
myself for not
having the tools or the knowledge to
understand how to better direct my team
because it is really disheartening for
me to see how much hard work has gone
into this year from our entire
organization and to see the community
backlash that they've received by
association with a hundred thieves
that's really disappointing for me and I
know that I need to do better and as we
now know
despite that glimmer of success in 2018
their performance didn't exactly
translate into 2019 but in a fashion
uncharacteristic of new teams they
started to pick themselves back up come
the summer albeit after a flurry of
roster changes thanks i teleport you can
finish it up to five members a hundred
days look at again their first victory
and they might just do it at some random
I must defend three versus five Apollo
barely alive but the turrets are not as
they keep going for
pick it up your second straight wins
both of these get a rip through the next
two towers and continue the little bit
of momentum it's enough to get enough
thick here as though this time towards
the fountain dive under the Nexus and
take that weight of a cloud nine one
turn is gone hundred feet stood over the
plate on a backlash spot watch beautiful
fibers gonna go down without anything to
his name and now the Nexus a is open
they're gonna find these girls they're
gonna find their win three in a row 400
bees there's still a long way to go but
a hundred thieves have stayed true to
what they stood for when they first
jumped into League of Legends they
haven't been afraid to make changes and
shake things up staying true Dan made
shots call of duty routes the
organization's foray into eSports didn't
stop at League of Legends since by
analyzing their roster back in August of
2018 100 thieves have quickly become one
of the best and most beloved teams in
Call of Duty thank you to Matt easy John
Robinson 100 thieves for the opportunity
for me to be a part of this amazing
organization and team I know the amount
of work that he puts in and day in and
day out and how much of a super fan kind
of will be honest that he is
but on top of that I made this all top
of dome let's run it up they're a rabble
of characters led by one of God's
biggest current personalities they're
loud in your face and most importantly
compete with the best of them and top of
all that
on may 5th 2019 they've brought a
hundred thieves something they've been
chasing since their inception inside of
this house sent behind his war machine
did he break he's old easy and find
water you take it down for the train
they're coming through you know that
jumper in the heart just to
came to my hand this is the first
championship 100t has brought home and
we want to do it for name he's been such
just an amazing owner to us and Fred I
couldn't be happier to get this check
four hundred feet and then just weeks
later they brought home another one
right here what a cluster is actually
gonna connect onto slasher drop sub
[Applause]
hundreds do it
Genji
there's no doubt that a hundred thieves
of burst into the eSports world but it's
not what happens on stage that makes
this org different from the rest what
makes them different is the brand
they've built outside of eSports the
camera in hand let the outside will see
everything kind of attitude that
nadeshot built himself on you got this
flip screen right I know how to love no
but you don't want to look at the flip
screen you're trained to look at
yourself don't look at yourself okay you
want to look directly into the camera
look at the camera you want to make sure
you enunciate you got a project YouTube
how about you doing why here true to the
content meets Pro play brand that nature
envisioned a hundred thieves were quick
to add a massive sponsors right off the
bat when they're LCS team started so did
the heist their weekly documentary
series that follows the trajectory of
their team and brings fans directly into
the team house it's truly a boardroom
meets vlog operation and that struck a
chord with the gaming world master chefs
today with the one thing that amazing
said yesterday is that he wants to get
to know you guys a little bit better so
we're gonna cook together teams that
cook together win together bang oh boy
yeah there you go I like the gucci
wallet
[Music]
hell yeah look like money and I love it
you look like money yeah you look like
money like good you look you look rich
you got a Porsche of Rolex Gucci shoes
gucci wallet and i know how much money
you make you're rich from the outside
looking in this move looked like a good
one
it was flashy and the players had some
swagger this new house looked expensive
and legit and from the inside it was a
win-win
they'd leveraged outside investment to
pad some flash for their team and turned
that into content so that's how it
started
gilbert hands them some cash and nading
company turned it into a league of
Legends team and a growing YouTube brand
but there was more to come they
announced a partnership with redbull
created the first ever eSports locker
room in conjunction with fashion
marketplace app stock X and outfitted
their team in Yeezys at the beginning of
our season
our first match ever I told every
individual on our roster that if you
meet optic gaming in our first match
ever I'm gonna buy you a pair of Yeezy
350 boots
I said this me once before I'll say it
again I don't want to get too corny that
first match you guys put against optic I
know it's like six months ago but it
meant so much to me and everybody our
organization that you guys pulled
through and validated what we were
trying to do in our first game ever
that's how great stock X is because they
made this happen so they wanted to be a
part of this and show you guys love and
it really helped me because I didn't
have to pay like an outrageous amount of
money so whoo I got a cop-out shout the
stock backside while Gilbert's initial
investment and the success of their
league franchise kick-started their year
in 2018 nadeshot and his crew were
looking elsewhere to take the brand from
an upstart eSports team that also sells
shirts here and there to
larger-than-life
and it doesn't get much bigger than
Drake he obviously had a really big
announcement this past week we had
screwed Ron and Drake they led our
series a which is a round of investment
you know this Drake and scooter
announcement that we just dropped on
social media and obviously in this video
you weren't aware this is something that
we've been working on for about six
months in the span of one year's time an
organization that started as an idea was
now co-owned by one of the most famous
people on planet earth so there was
nothing left to do but go bigger this is
that second investment the team has
taken off fortnight like it has for many
in the gaming space also exploded for a
hundred thieves they were one of the
first orcs to strike when the game
started to rise in prominence but for a
hundred thieves the game of some match
made in heaven
they immediately started signing some of
the biggest names in the game to their
team World Cup is gonna be the biggest
spectated event in history I guess for
fortnight so I think it's like 20,000
people can fit in the stadium which is
absolutely crazy if I was someone the
World Cup I would be able to support my
family in ways that I couldn't can't do
right now yeah it's a lot of money to
have I don't know if I'm ready for the
responsibility but I'm ready to win
winning to me and my family I don't
really think much about the money ever
since I started playing this game I've
always wanted to be known as the best
player and so for me it's kind of I'm
always playing for that title I want to
be like a legend in the sports not just
a player it says a lot about the score
the skill and I think but there it is on
your screen cease and elevate 1.8
million dollars a great performance from
everyone in the top 20 from everyone who
made it to here across weeks of grueling
competition it pays off in a big way but
it didn't stop there they also went
right after streamers this content
focused world is something few
understand more intimately than nadeshot
because frankly that's where he thrives
the original idea behind a hundred teams
was to build something bigger that
all-encompassing that was
all inclusive that people could really
feel like they were part of because they
believed in what we were creating and
what it stood for from the get-go the
brand was gonna be defined by the
creators that we brought underneath our
roof you know I wanted other individuals
who were excelling at what they do day
in and day out I wanted them to be
excited to be a part of a bigger
collective and so it was really really
important to me to find creators that I
believed in
in fact the move towards dreamers their
big personalities and the world of
twitch has been so huge for a hundred
thieves that they took it one step
further
all right I'm kitchen a lot everyone
this is our second I would love to learn
how to do maybe like some lap I'm in
agreement please wait so the art yeah
all right what are we doing today we're
doing a hundred Tina's hostel am I
supposed to call it something else
itself hundred tiny piece on tenth house
to LA they quite literally put internet
personalities and a house together so
they could [ __ ] around and make videos
specifically the addition of courage
served as a jumping-off point for more
lifestyle and vlog content rather than
just strictly gameplay welcome to the
nature and courage show they change the
name the courage and nadeshot show in
IIIi didn't have anything to do with
that in many ways this show encapsulate
a lot of what a hundred thieves has come
to be it's about personalities that
transcended the games that they play
much like what nadeshot envisioned a
hundred thieves to be when the brand was
nothing more than a few shirts and a
twinkle in the mind of an anime obsessed
20-something did you create your own
anime dude I'm not kidding I have
thought about that I really believe that
I Jaden Smith it if I took the time to
really sit down and come up with a
universe and a concept for like an anime
I would can crush it I'm not even
kidding I have chills right now and
Gohan defeats cell with a one-armed
Kamehameha and he's got his dad talking
to him from the afterlife go on you can
do this [ __ ] but with success always
comes controversy and the first
significant spat four hundred thieves
happened recently with popular
fortnight's streamer Nick mercs
the two parties started their
relationship just as fortnight and
notably Nick's channel we're taking off
and well he became massive racking up
tens of thousand viewers at a time on
his channel while also performing in
fortnight eSports but as far as the king
of tilted towers was concerned the
relationship wasn't as mutually
beneficial as he'd originally hoped and
he made that very clear
I mean we went out there the plan was
for me to grow and in turn that would
grow 100 thieves right that was my role
you know
he made some promises to me as a friend
and how we were gonna do it how he was
going to take care of me it just didn't
end up happening then I mean are they
doing good work over her thieves you
know but for me will you give me your
word and you promise certain things to
me as a friend and a business partner
and I put years of time into into
something that we that we basically
started and then everything changes and
I don't get what I was promised I mean I
promise with it you know so it is what
it is I have a lot of respect for what
Nick has done with his career I'm sorry
that Nick feels the way that he does I'm
not going to make a comment or statement
on the situation at hand I just don't
think that there's any point in having
this back and forth it's just a tough
situation all around
so that's all you guys are gonna hear
for me on on the matter this was a first
for a hundred thieves a player coming
out and prominently claiming that the
organization mistreated him Nick even
commented on his relationship with
nature explicitly I don't hate the guy
you know I definitely don't hate them
but I don't like them you know him and I
are not cool we're never gonna be cool I
don't want nothing to do with them I
never do business with him I'll never
sit down at a table with him ever again
quite possibly the most staggering thing
about a hundred thieves exist outside
the world of gaming entirely their
apparel has extended its reach past
games past which and into the street
where and fashion zeitgeist when you
really take a look at the success that
they've had in the apparel space I think
nadeshot having his own history being a
fan of sneaker culture being a fan of
street wear you know he gets the concept
of those limited drops you know when you
see somebody now 100 thieves hoodie you
know that they're wearing a hoodie that
was hard to get and I think for
specifically for gamers
and for eSports fans 100 thieves has
done a great job of putting all of those
ingredients together
to build this amazing kind of like hi
I've trained that ad lay on it during
2018 both of their apparel drops sold
out instantly with the most recent one
generating over half a million dollars
in revenue in under five minutes and
he's selling on stock ex for more than
double the initial price this trend
doesn't look like it's gonna slow down
either made recently announced the
acquisition of Doug barber a former head
of the renowned athletics and streetwear
brand reigning champ
you know we've spent the last you know
you and I worked on recruiting and
hiring Doug for almost nine months so
like that that whole experience learning
about what the fashion industry what the
men's apparel industry looks like
finding a senior executive to come in
and lead that for us
I think the like the potential for that
business is almost unlimited right now
and so I'm really really excited to see
Doug the team that he builds in the
creative vision that he has and how we
can help help bring that to life
recently a hundred thieves announced yet
another massive investment in their
company thirty five million dollars in
Series B funding yeah you say you say
cuz you did a lot of hard work on this
we have raised thirty five million
dollars from artist capital management
oh my god that's a lot of money thirty
five million dollars I never seen so
much money in my life
it hit the bank account and I thought
we're about to run up a check but then
Johnson we have to be fiscally
disciplined or financially discipline
fiscally responsible fiscally
responsible got the exact phrasing he
used yes that's a lot of that's a lot of
zeros a lot of commas a lot of ends it's
a lot of responsibility it is a lot of
responsibility it is a lot of
responsibility which I don't like that
word paired with this announcement was
the unveiling of their massive downtown
Los Angeles team facility that will pull
their eSports operations out of assorted
mansions and into their state-of-the-art
facility I am so incredibly excited
because this is the moment at
and I have been waiting for for a very
long time now
we love our players we wanted to bring
them here right now we got our lead team
and our Cod team and a bunch of other
people and our creators wanna bring
everybody under one under one roof and
this is a 15,000 square foot facility
that will yell the house everyone that
we have now and everyone that will
continue to build with in the future
we're talking an apparel retail space
enough team practice rooms to house two
more full eSports teams massive editing
and content space lounges couches
everything you'd expect from eSports
most glamorous organization they'd shot
himself even teased to jump back into
counter-strike after their earlier
attempt to get into the scene was
short-lived
just days after he went live with the
announcement aspirationally of course
I've always wanted to be a part of other
games I think csgo is the top of mine
for me just because we had a csgo team
at one point and unfortunately it was
just a very messy situation with a lot
of different variables that we could not
foresee and we had to release that team
we're getting us
we're getting some things out there now
we're in [ __ ] got 100 days come and
so with this latest news that vision of
scuff controllers championship trophies
off white sneakers Louis Vuitton bags
and boardroom deal closings has somehow
come true this organization has
surpassed these sports in an
unprecedented way because they don't
just bring you to the game they show you
a lifestyle something serious but casual
a little bit of Chicago hot dogs and a
little bit of Los Angeles fast-food you
don't just want to cheer them on you
want to act like them vlog like them and
dress like them and feel like you were a
part of something born on the internet
but built into celebrity something taken
you want to be a food
[Applause]
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring that notification bell for unique
bite-sized videos you will find anywhere
else
heat up art Instagram Twitter and
Facebook pages
[Music]